(electronic music)
- [Jason] Anything you
can do on a snowboard,
you can do on a mountainboard.
(loud rocks)
I love the feeling of being in nature
and charging down the mountain.
(intense drum music)
I wanted to keep that
feeling all year round,
so we built what's called a mountainboard.
(electronic music)
My name is Jason Lee,
and I'm Creative Director
for MBS Mountainboards.
I've done mountainboarding for 27 years.
A mountainboard is a
combination of a skateboard, a snowboard,
even a mountain bike,
all rolled into one
to create the feeling of
snowboarding on land.
(calm music)
So in the early '90s, my friend and I
decided to build a mountainboard.
When we started making 'em
we really had no idea about
any manufacturing techniques whatsoever.
We'd go to auto part stores,
we'd go to junkyards,
and piece together
these things to, you know,
make a functioning board.
- We still had a frame
system at that point.
- [Jason] Watching mountainboarding
grow from literally
our garage to a global phenomenon is
incredibly satisfying.
There are mountainboarders
in probably over 30 countries right now.
It was really important for us from
the very beginning to make sure that
it was not just a product,
it was a sport.
(upbeat electric guitar)
It is, believe it or not, very easy to do.
The coolest thing about
it, is that you can
go out on an adventure
anywhere you're at.
So you don't have to
travel hours and hours
or days to go some place cool.
You can ride a mountainboard
anywhere you desire.
You can ride it on grass, dirt, pavement.
You could ride it on dirt roads,
BMX tracks;
it's virtually limitless.
(upbeat electric guitar)
Mountainboarding has
brought a lot of friends
into my life.
And just kind of a feeling of community.
It gives me a sense of
purpose to get outdoors
and maybe create some jumps.
And being able to bring
mountainboarding to
people around the country,
around the world,
is a fantastic feeling.
(bell chime)